[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the guy that I kissed that's the guy
take him away under guard okay waiting
you betray the Son of man with a kiss no
my lord I would follow you to the gates
of hell
please Judas what what are you doing
fighting man Judas is really trying to
get in there with Jesus
yes surprise was that me wait you don't
know oh yeah oh yeah Judas I mean he's
into that Mammon mr. Mistoffelees
unnatural shape what I've never heard
that heard that I mean it's all over
Nazarene just ask him hath you the time
I forget too much wine after the wedding
it's in there starts playing grab-ass
with Matthew I've never heard this story
no one tells me anything
I mean he gets in there he's going in
there so aggressively I mean I just
thought it was a goofy context on tax
day Judas gets around I mean right I'm
gonna get his work done plus the thing
with hair is great
no shut up what happened with hearing
just and today it was like this listen
boom I mean Pythagorean is cute angles
it was like geometric No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this June which marks louder the
Crowder's fifth annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe to learn about and
appreciate all the cultures this world
has to offer they gave us the Kia
Sorento I don't know so glad because by
the way cultural appropriation months to
appropriate is to appreciate very glad
to be here with you today we have
Michael Knowles on the show we talking
with Michael knows a little bit later
and everyone here seems very confused in
the studios okay Michael knows we'll be
talking about the new Donald Trump polls
why it's I don't quarter black gears we
have audio way then we have half Asian
style okay and then of course Jill they
Dennis Rodman is here I just want to go
home and go to the wrong flight I go
home it's a problem for everyone right
now Delta isn't even giving out snacks
home oh yes we do have some some facts I
guess in North Korea but first let me
ask you this what do you think is the
worst offense as far as pollsters
getting things wrong particular when it
comes to Donald Trump obviously people
will mostly answer Trump but let's get a
little more granular because we know
that one was they're bad when it comes
to South Korea the users a lot of people
don't know this audio way thank you for
helping with the research absolutely no
entering a Korean home you should always
take off your shoes as a sign of respect
and take off your hat as a sign of utter
contempt just to keep them guessing Wow
this year South Korean film parasite -
call me Oscar for Best Picture or as I
call it a gift and the Korean film award
for least shame brought to the family oh
yes it's a new category it's a different
deal they bury it in with the editors
and the technical oh they did this at
Commerce
and they kind of say it's always an
Asian who brings a shame to the family
are the ones that carry yeah and then
another fact about South Korea since the
1950s our national slogan has been South
Korea the one with food is helpful you
know if one phrase could describe it
it's always weird when I see psy from
South Korea he was a protest in the
capital at the inherently discriminatory
capitalist system but wait just grab
some binoculars examples Americans
here's not gonna go to Canada they're so
far removed from socialism let alone
actual communism you're in the place by
the way it's still not that free and
they talks their citizens in South Korea
yeah what what would you rather your the
South you're good you're good Korea and
there's bad Korea don't become bad Korea
what is the Korean accent is more
similar to Chinese what Bill does what
happened bill does before the show he
goes I'll just be say I'll put on some
sunglasses then people think you're
Korean
[Laughter]
yeah look look faux racial outrage is my
favorite thing white people they get so
comfortable you lure amend and then you
slam them when it's pronounced pas -
it's not curry not turn right three your
hair looks great natural hair I guess
the only the pop music in Korea in South
Korea is very gay yeah no I didn't say I
don't want to I don't want to tar all
women it's gay so before we go into the
news first everyone remember to stretch
before you pander
yeah yes but that brings us to right
away who did it better I do miss that
man yeah he was doing either he's doing
the time warp I think huh
or he's culturally appropriating because
he's appreciating and no one that was
upset
you know that's ours George Bush is not
he doesn't think that he's actually one
of these women who know what you doing
over here feet on this bro dude Matthew
McConaughey there hopefully keep your
pants on breaks into Michael Jackson's
Thriller and it's back I can't remember
a time when they weren't back yeah like
where do we go we're back again and we
you know and like we're here again I
needed more attention all right we will
be talking about the Donald Trump polls
little I'm looking forward to that
because a lot of people have been
they've been a little bit upset you
don't need to worry about it it's not do
not lose sleep over it do lose sleep
over the naked Chris Cuomo video that
we're gonna have it Monday but do you
have any idea how hard it is to make
that go what Chris Cuomo the video is
uploaded life was doing naked his wife
was doing yoga then he was nailing
background right and you can't find the
clip anywhere I'm bettin CNN paid more
to make that go away than Bill O'Reilly
Skype with the purple apparatus just let
it live on this helps his image we'll
find it
so of course leading the news after you
know the nationwide call now to defund
the police which we'll be talking about
more on Monday and good morning about
club it was reported this week that one
of the longest-running TV shows I
believe ever cops
has been canceled think of that for a
second now
they're canceling cops because it has
cops in it interesting it's not you it
was like cooler there are some bad cops
there's some good cops
no cancel cop all code yeah what why
because there are cops I understand your
grievance well I don't yeah it's because
they're always abusive that's why right
yeah well one thing I'm kind of joking
because it turns out that the initial
reports was training they were actually
incorrect and we always have to correct
it when the media the show is not
canceled entirely it's going to be
reformatted it comes back in a different
way this is how production works we
actually have from the new format an
exclusive sneak peek tonight No
[Music]
state unions award no cops and I will
stay tuned yeah excited about this
operating program but you have to see
the next installment um are you gonna
call I want to make the joke so is this
other with public restrooms they've been
closed obviously thousands of protesters
have been packing the streets new york
city's public urination problem is on
the rise and so they've been talking
about here so as we all struggle with
the new normal
new york city gets to stay the same look
I don't know what that snare would be
like if it didn't smell like urine all
that I don't know effects work take a
dump right in front of me really yes a
human take a crap no show and there's a
cop right knee rising to be fair that
we'll need to clarify New York City
because of additional II we worked in as
New York right Rockwell and actually fit
rocking does have it does have they have
pissing Ralph and that's a problem he's
doing better
yeah yeah kissing kissing Ralph are you
pissing right now applying to yourself
for Schenectady missing Ralphie migrants
yeah he's a Romer
he's a roaming pissing Ralph turning in
let's turn to the latest peaceful
protest news a Wisconsin man threatened
to unleash this is my new hero unleash
beans if a protest turned into a riot I
love it well he was armed with 12 crates
of what he called his riot control beans
most affected by the debacle of course
auntie Fong let us pray in silence
wanna go tree climbing Thomas J his face
hurts and where is this fences you can't
see without his glasses put his glasses
are in real life sometimes the fascist
twin it's sad and sometimes they
sometimes they're tiny fascist but
they're metal the fascists die after
this die when they release their stinger
that's what I thought don't be ologist
and you're not gonna go to know everyone
that was a thing you're running out of
these years yeah I hear about this a lot
in the wine business right well now we
have the jet we have the Japanese killer
Hornets I think they call him Asian
killer Hornets no because they're not
just from Japan
well they filed a grievance yeah so hey
your they call him non non white yeah
and white you ever in God - yeah yeah
yeah really
I'm up so laughing it was painful but
the AMT venom which ironically is just
from another it's it's from a lot vien
killer Hornet just like the Brazilian
Wandering Spider it's a venom actually
gives you boners really death by
priapism Oh
death by long painful erection from the
Brazilian Wandering Spider hey mal could
you could you write could Mel Gibson
write a worse way to die
look guys I got an idea for spider wait
that's that's what Monica was helping
bill with Oh got to do what you got to
do to get rid of priapism okay okay I
don't think you know what priapism is or
you wouldn't joke about it you wouldn't
take it so lightly in social justice
news is very serious
these are serious things yes death
boners can you imagine that cuz at first
you would like the first you really 5-10
minutes you look guys look at this wait
come in and verify right it's kind of
cool the novelty than 30 40 minutes in
you might say think there's a problem
here for hours and I'm getting
lightheaded and no your doctor died and
it can't be open casket does it go away
just like forever like a monument to why
you died I don't know
by the way of a story after other shows
that oh boy talk about you guys know
what I'm talking about
it's social and social justice news New
York City they'll have a street named
black lives matter on each borough
progressive yeah so this is what you
know this is a push that it's not
necessarily new now what a lot of you
I'm taking considerations this means
that of course they're going to have to
rename it already guess it'll have to be
changed so the Brooklyn City Council is
currently debating over whether it will
be Martin Luther King jr. Street Malcolm
X way or I hope you brought your
steering wheel lock Boulevard so that's
very apt yeah probably shouldn't change
and probably yeah it's really it seems
like it should be it's more of a
guideline yeah that's great yeah right
right
what's a rule were we wouldn't want a
victim blade no finally this is another
one what because we're international
here at an International Wine
Competition this was a big surprise it
wasn't a French wine that one wasn't
even an American wine if he gets a
bottle shock you know a Mexican wine was
named the best Cabernet Sauvignon in the
world did you have you tried this no I
know once again wine but I don't know
this one have you had Mexican wine that
should be the best wine in the world
nope really then why just racist no
because they can't make great wine and
because in a second it's because of
location location climate dog-whistle
quite so I'm it's a dog will you say
they're not bringing the best is that
what you said no they're bringing their
best when you granny girl they will say
I will give you this good when you look
at the judging process it seems that
there might have been some inherent bias
[Music]
they're my shipmate
[Music]
see
remember Cheryl is the racist by the way
is it considered Mexican face if a
Colombian does it can't understand why
Takashi 69 can say the n-word repeatedly
when he's half Mexican in Porto Rican I
don't know what he yeah he blends in
bouncy hop how many tattoos does it take
until it turns into blackface right yeah
I don't see hop well you know you need
trampoline with kids bouncing up where
Gerald used to hang out sorry they got
America we need you to speak American
you mean a bounce house is it a call to
bounce i'm bouncing i don't know i have
no idea where you're from mr. I don't
know Chinese or Korean bouncy and they
do Baba's house so it was descriptive
okay well listen I apologize to those
who tuned in to the show for my accuracy
and children's novelty toy you won't
find it here you lost them thanks I have
any ball pen jokes and it's a bulb go
back to the this is why we need
immigration reform screw you and your
bouncy hops okay right YouTube so let
into the polls here because everyone has
been talking about this and and I think
listen polls matter you can't be someone
who entirely discounts them but the
methodology matters as well and I think
we and we'll come back to this polls are
just as much or they have morphed into
just as much a tool to try and shape
public opinion as much as they're
supposed to be sort of a temperature
gauge of public opinion but this is the
newest CNN poll let them say it is this
translating into support for his
opponent in November Jill Biden it
overwhelmingly is take a look at this
matchup that we have that's just it's
unbelievable to me
55 we're seeing a voice over by the
killers from polar top right
only 41 percent say they vote for the
president and that 50 is so important
because it means that Biden's over 50% I
went back that look at the 2016 from
this point onward Hillary Clinton never
reached this level she never got there
she never got above 50% so this means
especially looking at the other polling
that the president will have to take
back okay shave your chest or wear a tie
[Laughter]
about that learned my polling
methodology through years of time spent
abroad in lockers Stephen 55 by the way
is greater than 50 as he said yeah very
very key point and I mean when I say I
mean more than my right your left if you
do this if you do this really and then
I'm so itchy here it's like I'm wearing
a sweater
[Laughter]
they shouldn't have been silly and this
is a perfect example of the ego and
Trump the Trump campaign sent a cease
and desist letter to CNN which of course
they've ignored but and I don't say that
he shouldn't send a cease and desist
because it's inaccurate right I just
don't think it looks good yeah but let's
look at the actual methodology the pull
so it may come as no surprise that the
source of the poll are the worst polls
that they're discussing there for Donald
Trump is CNN yeah that the actual source
for the bull and if you're taking into
the methodology again for people who go
this looks really bad yeah when I
couldn't ohana second if you're taking
different sample sizes only 25 percent
were Republicans 32 percent Democrats
and 44% independence and what really
matters there is whoever's conducting
the poll that high number of
independents you can really stack that
that oh yeah you can
you could handpick independence yeah
that's a that's a terrible 33% of people
that voted in last election of
Republicans right right but that 25
that's crazy you shouldn't have that low
it's absolutely when you take that that
polls it's surprising it's surprising
that he's even as close yeah it should
be far worse than that I just I mean
just a feel like from a reliability
standpoint I mean is anyone thinking
that CNN has like a solid list of
conservative phone numbers right right
exactly
I don't know they're like well I looked
through my friends list yeah no all
right here let's pick these guys right
done yeah pretty much you know I want
that too on Jonathan cronies formerly
concerned was the inspiration for my
nasal reconstructive surgery and that's
why I'm able to be as articulate as I am
so we just pulled the family four or
five times and let's look by the way
let's look at how CNN is framing their
own poll okay a couple of things here
but um this is where they say that there
has been overwhelming support for the
protest but see the catch this is one of
the first sort of measures of whether or
not people are agreeing with these
protests or not and what we see is that
they overwhelmingly are agreeing with
the protest eighty four percent say that
they are justified these peaceful
protests okay
eighty-three percent said that these
these peaceful vigil the word peaceful
was slipped in there eighty four percent
of people support peaceful protests what
about what about violent protests right
did we ask them yeah the number drops to
27% oh and keep in mind that's with a
sample draw of seventy five percent non
Republican voters right and we know that
we can historically trust CNN polls
because they called Hillary Clinton the
winner by what 99% but and this is so
when it's 33% they do 25 that's an eight
point swing in the poll right so it
would actually jump drop it down
eight points at least three point four
percent plus or minus he's pretty much
right neck and neck and by the way
another thing they over sampled and they
said this they over sampled black
non-hispanic people by two hundred and
fifty out of twelve hundred and
something right over sampled a
population right now that's very
frustrated with the president either
rightfully so or not right in this poll
yeah Dennis Rodman has spent a lot of
time in Korea when he's doing
statistics yeah I want North Korea to
understand it I won't go home you know I
watched the documentary on Dennis Rodman
by the way it's alarming as to how much
you look like a white Dennis Rodman
makes me wildly uncomfortable i watch
this documentary and my wife and I felt
bad for him because you see his rough
upbringing but then you realize there
are a ton of people who all and this is
a perfect example of when people talk
about privilege there are a ton of
people who've had just as terrible if
not bringing who didn't turn in to place
yeah when he had the whole blindside
thing happening - we're a family takes
it in and tries to help him out not
everybody who's had a rough upbringing
yes that same treatment but to his
credit he's not really a racist which I
appreciate about him he did talk he's
very open about the fact that he was
black white he saw it as some people
were hateful in the South versus people
and he's open about a lot of things in
sexuality and this is some that I think
is very important because first off
we've showed how the the sampling their
talk about peaceful protests can you
name me any major city where over the
course of these two weeks any major city
I'm not talking about twenty people down
in a suburb any major city where once
the lights went out the protest didn't
result in any violence and even when I
say that I'm not saying any protest
where there wasn't twenty five million
dollars in property damage later on
Minneapolis alone let's just compare it
to the Tea Party
meaning zero crime that's the standard
zero cleaner than when they got there
any big city where that's been the case
in the last two weeks you can't name
again there have been isolated protests
small and I want to be in the suburbs
middle a day and then the lights go down
and the tear gas comes out and by the
way it should be a hundred percent of
Americans okay with peaceful protests
yes that's part of one of the rights
that we have we can protest injustice
peacefully I would answer everybody
should be fine I would answer yes if the
question was peaceful protein or
whatever percent it was fascist B's
if their instinct here's something
that's pretty important there's a
difference between polling people on
what they think of a personality versus
specific policies right so let's go to
some specific policies because they talk
about Donald Trump now he's not polling
very well and any given area but the
poll is really what do you think of
Donald Trump on blank well when you go
to specific policies and I think this is
important because 71% of Americans we've
talked about this they support using the
National Guard to address protests and
demonstrations that's 71% so that's
different from how do you feel about
peaceful protests 58 percent supported
sending in the actual military right 58
percent supported 71 percent support
using a National Guard which candidates
support the National Guard which
candidate excoriated the president for
wanting to send in the National Guard
there's only one person who's had the
balls to say all right we're gonna sit
in the National Guard and that's going
against the green with everyone in the
media and entertainment reso it's
important to keep that in context now I
say this because that was pointed to as
the most as extreme right-wing right
radical right-wing extremists fascism
they want to send in the National Guard
seventy one percent of Americans not
saying that polling makes something
morally justify now in this case
constitutionally I believe it's morally
justified to protect the rights of
citizens it's legal that being said 71
percent of Americans support it now
let's contrast that that's radical
right-wing extremism sent a National
Guard with radical left-wing extremism
defunding the police and renaming
streets and buildings the public outcry
over George Floyd's death has ignited
debate and action on police reform and a
lot of people advocating for what they
have taken to calling defunding the
police the phrase even appears in large
yellow letters on the newly named black
lives matter Plaza on 16th Street near
the White House yeah because now you're
saying no no no before Jose no no that's
not the only part because they're not
just defunding the police if you look at
the Seattle autonomous zone they're
replacing them with SoundCloud rappers
who now have who are armed and extorting
businesses to fund the food and the
weapons in those areas right lissa so
you know but we just don't call them
police right listen bill they're just
those rappers are just waiting for their
break okay give them a minute
yeah all right not all of the tables at
Starbucks this is better I hate to go
back to that Takashi six nine nine
characters but I will say even in a
culture that is phony with you know
gangster and how tough they are
for some reason kids have decided to
support the heart gangster rapper who
went to prison for snitching on the gang
and then was allowed out because of his
asthma and coronavirus listen not all
but most of you the generation your hit
the generation Z hip hop your posses
snitches get asthma snitches get
ventolin y'all like a blinged-out
inhaler we did drugs that could harm us
so we're talking about police defunding
the police wildly unpopular only 16% of
Americans support defunding the police
while 65 percent oppose it 19 percent
are unsure I guess those are the the
soundcloud rappers but again this is so
remarkable because some people say well
you're misrepresenting it defund the
police that just that just means
defunding it to a degree some people
believe that but that's not what is
being demanded by black lives matter you
have the mayor of Minneapolis who
checked his privilege and recognize his
own brokenness as a white person be
drummed out of the Corps by thousands of
people for saying that he didn't support
the outright abolition of police that is
not a minority opinion that's the
Minneapolis City Council opinion let's
be clear so even if you're saying well
that poll might be might be tainted 65
percent opposed it only 16 percent of
Americans support that policy so this is
why this is important to me when they
constantly say we have this radical
extreme right wing right wing on YouTube
right people going on a radical rabbit
hole let's take the furthest right
opinion as it was presented sending in
the National Guard how dare you this is
fascism 71% of Americans don't see it
that way they support it then let's take
the furthest left opinion that we can
have right now in this current conflict
defunding the police 65%
opposed to it so I asked you which wing
as represented officially by the heads
of their party is more radical yeah and
if you listen to just that how the media
described it you would think that
everybody wants to defend the police and
that that's a great idea right so in
this same poll they said how our race
relations generally in America right so
this kind of speaks to the same media
vice and people are like oh they're
terrible and they go well how about in
your area oh they're fantastic right
they just flipped and I'm like that's
the media bias because you see this on
the screen every day you think oh things
are terrible everywhere but when you
look around outside reality it's not
terrible
tribal it's not terrible but every day
okay North Korea's getting better every
day
go home he's trying they won't let me go
home he had to be coached on even though
it's his character but we can't he was
walking around the office going oh yeah
where's my glowy finger anyone gonna
dress up like a girl alien hit the
notification bell hit all notifications
if you're watching of course on YouTube
right now because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot you might be listening
on the iTunes Apple podcast if you're
not operating listen they're in the road
and please do join one club it a lot of
credit calm smile Club it's the only way
that we make any dollar dollar bills as
Takashi $6.99 would say and course he
would say that's his rhyme are those
dollar bills no that's is really you'll
be kicked off of whose line is it anyway
as a cameo this is another point we need
to get you then we do have to have we
have Michael Knowles coming up after
this and I want you again you to tell me
what you see is because it was tough to
pick them out what you see as the worst
example of of media bias as it relates
to polls there are several reasons by
the way that pollsters have gotten
things wrong absolutely everyone need to
be trust silver trust nate silver now
it's just like that's the [ __ ] that's
the stick that's his website subtext is
like a gift now it has a lot to do like
you said how the media covers Donald
Donald Trump there's something called
social social desirability bias then I'm
gonna get a little bit wonky but I'll
try and keep it short because I know
that you you know we are in pink hairdos
social desirability bias Kay it's the
tendency of respondents in polls or
surveys they lie about their actual
beliefs sometimes because they want to
answer in a way that they view is more
socially acceptable okay so as it
relates to voting this social
desirability bias I'm saying this what
you know what it is if you haven't been
to college you'll probably hear about it
there it created something called the
Bradley effect okay
named after Tom Bradley he was a black
candidate lost in the 80s and California
was a gubernatorial race despite the
fact that he was leading in the polls
but people didn't want to be perceived
as racist
vote for that guy and then they went
back homeless are you voting for that
guy soon now with a baton so um they
said they were gonna vote for him
because even though they weren't going
to vote for him right and then there
have been case studies in this now let's
for context take a look at the way the
media is actually covered president
Trump most presidents would use a crisis
like that as an opportunity to bring the
country together and to denounce hatred
but not this president over the last 12
months
Trump has instead amplified his racist
rhetoric and policies we read about the
president the president is a racist as a
matter of fact I've known that the
president is a dangerous human being a
would-be dictator who would move in the
direction that he's doing president
Trump today denying that his racist
tweets were racist today it is the
United States of America
the former beacon of the free world that
is the subject of global revulsion and
disgust because of the raw ugly racism
and ethno-nationalism of our president
and by the way every single source is
the previous clip right yeah see CNN
clip
knew for a long time Donald Trump could
be a racist
dangerous man really how'd you know that
I seen it all the other times I said
Jake Tapper and [ __ ] good ok now we
understand so the principle again not
wanting people we talk about the Bradley
effect to perceive you as racist well
how do you think people are going to
respond when the media consistently says
if you support Donald Trump you're a
racist racist racist racist the MOG
assemble the okay simple which is by the
way Don't Tell home alone - it's on the
cover - trying out loud this is racist
this is white supremacy if you vote for
Donald Trump it's white supremacy check
your priveledge voting for Donald Trump
is white privilege what you probably
will want to avoid being perceived as
racist and so that's another reason that
the polls can't be relied upon not
always but specifically we've seen
historically with Donald Trump yeah and
not only do they do that not only do
they portray him as a racist with no
evidence on the screen at all
they also remove everything that was
actually for all the celebrity
apprentice well right and that guy sucks
at everything the video that we saw the
other night from his campaign that was
taken down by Twitter Brian but he you
know had a problem with being in a video
that they did public footage right and
every full quote all the full videos
Donald Trump's a racist well if you play
the next 30 seconds you'll see he wasn't
talking about that yeah all of those
things are pulled off so the only thing
that you see is what they have to say
about him not facts right what I think
the other part of this is how many
people are out there going oh I'm gonna
vote for they say publicly I'm gonna
vote for Donald Trump and then are
actually gonna go home and vote for
someone else far less right consider the
social desirability and and if you need
proof Laura in 2016 right I mean that
like if the fact that they think that
this is accurate polling shows the fact
that they're desperate to create it
right so I definitely get the point
about why the letter sent and I'm with
you I disagree with the letter being
sent I think it looks weak right you
just sent one that just said you're
wrong that would have rather than
anything rubbed right right that would
have been better but ultimately the
arrival of your by polling is wrong I do
have a question for you than a legal
front so I read the entire letter and at
the bottom of it it basically said
because you've been notified you can't
destroy any information related to this
polling and they list it out just like a
paragraph of things do you think at some
point they're gonna go and try to say
like just release to us how you
conducted the poll can these - its
internal emails about conducting this
poll like was it biased are they trying
to prove that by
so that's called the litigation hold
it's a notice that you send you don't
have to send it so people have an
obligation to preserve things if they
think there might be a litigation but
you put them on notice to say preserve
all your records because we might come
have to get them from you as part of
litigation yeah but it's not says that
it's taxes is everything they wrote
facts similes right now so when you look
and you look at how the poll came about
and what was the purpose in doing it or
what were the conversations that made
something that they're looking at for
down the road which is why they sent
that notice in the first place again you
could have sent that notice without the
rest of it right but you know either way
look there's there's certainly some
thought winners right and I want to go
back to your point I think you're
absolutely right because people say well
it cuts both ways know what is the
likelihood of someone saying to a
pollster I'm gonna vote for Donald Trump
and then not I mean because answering a
pollster to their face or on the phone
yeah I'm voting for Donald Trump is the
equivalent to slapping your balls on the
table and say come on that's what it's
like right as opposed to the people who
are afraid kneeling it's but um I picked
up lack of collagen shea butter will
help it's just like a sequel to flubber
the point is bouncing off the walls
green tint yeah no I think it's
important to take in the context yeah
yeah that was marion doing there that's
always funny any of a Canadian or a Brit
or now you have South Koreans trying to
mimic the America inner city black
accent it's like you're not though
you're not if yeah another thing it
isn't measured by polls but little
Michael Knowles in just two seconds here
there's simple approval and disapproval
right and it glosses over enthusiasm and
I know the logical so do the other
doesn't matter because people are they
going to vote or they're not now
actually it's a more significant
determiner in who actually gets out in
votes on Election Day and that's the
reason there's this huge discrepancy
between likely voters and then actual
voters news polls are likely voters and
specifically as really from from Al Gore
onward
outside of Barack Obama you can think of
Al Gore you can think of John Kerry with
John Edwards and then you can think of
Hillary Clinton of course there really
has been an enthusiasm problem on the
left so Hillary Clinton right she led
significantly among likely voters but
then trailed with actual voters now
recent polls they show that among
registered voters who support Trump 55%
of them are very enthusiastic about
backing them for Biden it's about how
it's half that 28% are very enthusiastic
and I tell you what those 28% are
committed to the lie yeah exactly well
and just to go to your point like when
they say I really know I'm going to
enthusiastically Biden's like you show
up in your eyes a little bit I swallowed
it back you got me that don't probably
forget just like Joe Biden will he'll
forget he's running for president by
lucky in the scene in Pope goes back to
your point 70 percent of the people that
said that they were voting for Trump
they said it's because I want Trump to
win 60% of the people voting for Biden
didn't say it because they liked Biden
they said it's they were voting against
Trump right right so that's not
enthusiasm for your candidate that's
just being pissed off in a moment that
might change drastically
ya know that's a good point we'll wrap
this up with I think it's important
again the most important takeaway from
this poll is a CNN is not a news
organization okay be like they would
have been better off they would have had
more cover if they didn't release this
poll it's even just the fact 75% non
Republican respondents on Allen let's
just just remember CNN look searched
high and low and as every pollster they
could can anyone come up with these
numbers no all right let's make our own
yeah nobody chromo was like I want to
get mr. Gallup on the phone this is
Chris Cuomo
well first off there is no mr. Gallup
and second you're naked I don't know if
this is another what I do
hmm well then I guess I'll take mr.
Quinnipiac way Chris yeah that's a good
idea so number one CNN is not a news
organization - there's a huge between
polling people on personality traits
like how do you think Donald Trump
presents the country do you think Donald
Trump is right versus specific policies
should we
the National Guard should we defund the
police those are the polls that you
should be looking at to get a more
accurate gauge at this point and still
taking into account that there is a huge
handicap 75% non Republican responders
with CNN and the most important takeaway
here is this shouldn't affect your your
voting pattern or your canvassing
patterns at all you still need to go out
you still need to change people's minds
that's what changed my mind right didn't
exist before the last election that's
what it's for it's to walk people down
the path of rationalizing their own
argument there are far more people as
you see with these individual policy
polls who are more conservative than
they realize so all of you have a job to
do that don't think Wow because there's
high enthusiasm Donald Trump's going to
win anyway assume that he won't assume
the worst and work for the best know
that these polls that are every time one
of these polls comes out they are used
to try and manipulate the American
public perception of elections just as
much as they used to be used to try and
gauge where the election is actually
going that's not the case anymore
polls are a political tool at this point
be aware of it and do your part we have
Michael knows coming up right after this
break
[Music]
[Music]
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business with
expressvpn not using a VPN specifically
expressvpn is like leaving it's like
leaving your front door unlocked every
time you go out and sure you might be
fine for years but when a break-in does
happen it's terrible and it's even more
important because how much more often do
you use your phone or computer then your
door you basement-dwelling [ __ ] right
you're probably doing that all the time
so you should at least protect yourself
there that one of the easiest ways to
protect yourself online and your data is
with express VPN you just click one
button on your computer your smart phone
it's done so go to expressvpn comm slash
crowder get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free protect everything
you do online what you do online should
be your business go to expressvpn
dot-com slash Crowder today and that
we've actually used them in some of our
videos here in looking at search results
and tomfoolery going on expressly
beyond.com slash Crider go go go go go
and leave the house
[Music]
if you're listening on audio
you're probably wondering what's
happening right now if you're not
listening on audio subscribe at Apple
podcast Google Play and Spotify oh hi
seen on the board do you guys have black
rifle coffee here no I'm sorry we only
carry good small batch coffee here well
it is great
small batch coffee well that really
can't be unless it's fresh roasted so
you know what is fresh roasted oh thank
you know what that means
you know what this is this is masala
quoi PK which of course in the
Indonesian my element finish and the
Indonesian language it's weasel coffee
you've made that up
no it's been past their digestive tract
that's discussed and then it's nature's
what processing yeah is it good that's
all right
are they investor philanthropist today
support good causes yeah that's it
causes veterans causes and you're first
responder causes but it doesn't matter
because they make good coffee so that's
what I'm wondering do you have any you
know what actually I'm I'm just gonna
order it let me get freshly roasted
black rifle coffee it's good
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder I
just broke a Zippo lighter on the arcade
machine
go to black rifle coffee calm slash
Crowder use a promo code Crowder you get
20% off they're a wonderful sponsor to
the show and this vintage roast is my
favorite coffee period we drink it we go
how many bags 15 bags in the office we
we kept having to up our order so if you
drink coffee drink better coffee that's
fresh roasted and delivered straight to
your door also a company that doesn't
hate everything you stand for like
Starbucks and Dunkin they want us to
remove the done I'm not going to Dunkin
Donuts block trifle coffee calm /
Trotter entering Crider 20% off
[Music]
all right this is always awkward ones
cultural appropriation month and have to
bring on a guest and I just see them not
at all I'm gonna Skype and they go it
they go I think you can see them talking
to their publicist sure like the mute
their mics are going on okay and what
the actually he's a host of a program
there at the Daily wire program and he's
an avid cigar smoker so on the web
extended form uh Club we'll talk about
that more or as black lives matter knows
him every negative stereotype of a white
guy host of the Michael knows show mr.
Noles how are you sir I'm doing very
well and I appreciate the intro because
the one thing that black lives matter
has gotten right is everything they've
said about me they're wrong about
everything else but I will admit they
got that part right
what is their chance been for you just
he looks kind of generically ethnic but
no one claims it ethnically ambiguous we
don't know what races Michael knows what
is you man so okay so they don't like
you let me ask you well your your can i
I don't know not letting the camera the
bag you're in DC right now right I am
yeah this is so I'm pretty much in the
heart of darkness at least I'm not in
the autonomous zone of Seattle but DC is
pretty crazy here I mean there are
boards up everywhere you know mostly
it's shop owners graffitiing
their own restaurants saying like we
support BLM please don't loot us you
know minority-owned business that kind
of thing and you know we were shooting I
do this show with senator Cruz called
verdict we were shooting at the White
House yesterday they were taping taping
at the White House I kit so we're
sitting there we were talking to the
chief of staff mark Meadows you know
you'd think pretty good sound proofing
no we actually had to cut at one point
because the the peaceful protesters
quote-unquote outside were so loud and
they were so close to the White House
right we were picking it up on our
podcast mics it's pretty wild out here
well you need to get a cardioid first
off but no we have something similar
except we have some workers in the
office next door the primarily
but one of them keeps coming in because
he wants a job and he thinks we need
drugs and that's not a joke not a joke
at all oh there whatever she's like man
what do you want I got aa I got what you
need and he actually did that oh and
then he came in one day in a motorcycle
accident and yeah like he had multiple
body parts in a cast it's like what
happened just come back from the
Revolutionary War like I'm rolling in
there's motorcycle still back there but
so different it's a good fight you know
bridging the cultural divide what have
you seen down there you know I went down
to Dallas Deep Ellum where everything
was boarded up and that's one thing you
know a lot of people they see the
protests that turn into riots they want
to say most of them are peaceful but
what you definitely notice is the media
they don't go down to deal with the
refuse right that's left over here I
trash what is it like like accurately in
DC is it pockets is it most of the city
what's the vibe
no it's its most of the city and
particularly in the areas with power you
know by the capital or by the White
House it's really closed up and the main
thing I'm noticing is people are just
afraid you know I mean this the Seattle
example is the one that I think is the
most extreme now right they basically
declared their own territory but there's
this kind of irony to it which is all of
these well-meaning mostly white liberals
actually believe what the radicals and
Tifa the radical Marxists the anarchists
what they all say is we want to get rid
of the police we want to get rid of
borders that's obviously BS because the
minute they take over a territory they
set up their own police gangs they set
up their own borders it it's not that
they want to get rid of government and
police they just want to get rid of your
government and police and guess what the
one they're bringing in ain't going to
be a whole lot nicer no no I well I've
heard that the the autonomous zone isn't
is entirely peaceful and there was a
there was a Bob Dylan cover band is that
not true you know one thing I always
noticed is they always say it's mostly
peaceful protests that unexpectedly
turned a little bit violent but the
rioters are totally different than the
protesters right even though they're in
the same place at the same time for the
same reason and they're dressed the same
way and they're the exact same people
right exactly so can you guys just
please do shirts and skins
[Laughter]
no no you're the easier for it you know
what the standard is that I say okay if
when you say peaceful as peaceful as all
of the Tea Party protests go yes and
then are you gonna consider violating
curfew
yeah actually as a matter of fact any
peaceful protest where they leave the
area cleaner than they found it major
city now I'm not talking about four
people on a street corner in
Poughkeepsie that's what they point to
they point to a suburban area where they
know everyone's carrying and so people
are there on their best behavior I don't
think there's been a single major city
over the course of two weeks that has
not seemed serious damage and I want ask
you this cuz you're more walkush than I
am there are two minds about this do you
think these riots affect how do you
think they affect the president's
chances good bad for reelection I think
he's got to show that he can step up and
stop them you know I like that president
Trump is I think he's taking the right
tone most of the tweets have been really
on message but I think what a lot of
people are looking at is they're saying
okay you're right about the tweets
you're all right about holding hearings
and tweets and things but you've got to
actually do something and this brings up
the real problem that conservatives have
which is conservatives don't control any
of the institutions you know there's
there's this crazy thing where the left
always talks about institutional racism
as though it's our fault conservatives
fault then I think the left controls
every major institution in the country
the media Hollywood big tech the Academy
on and on the administrative government
everything so if there is institutional
racism whose fault is that
right not to mention the unions and this
is one thing who is remarkable the turn
because I've talked about this with John
you know John Oliver is doing this video
listen I have consistently been
anti-union in the 21st century you know
I understand that at one point the
Industrial Revolution there was some guy
we're a little bit different now since
no one found hafez body times have
changed it is entirely consistent for me
and I do believe this to say hey let's
dissolve the police unions let's change
the structure there so that we can
actually have some accountability just
like I do the same way I feel for
teachers unions we should reward good
cops and we should expel and punish bad
cops but it is entirely inconsistent for
the left to in this instance say they
have a problem with police unions
because they are the ones who protect
these unions who by the way are the
biggest political donors in the country
bar none it's not even close
right and it's it's multiple public
sector unions right the police or a
public sector union the teachers or a
public sector union and the left does
very well with these guys you know they
think that when they get rid of the cops
things are going to become more peaceful
obviously that is not the case but there
was one incident in Virginia that to me
is the symbol of the whole thing which
is you know cops to be seen there were
no cops around
and these rioters like they were in
Baghdad in 2003 pulled down a statue
right they tie around to the neck pull
down the statue and the statue is it
comes tumbling down squishes one of the
rioters and overall just like everything
about this scene is sad but I think this
tells you the whole story which is that
when you pull down your history you pull
down your traditions and institutions
you think it's gonna free you actually
you're gonna get squished in 2003 was
not a good vintage for Baghdad by the
way you ever know you know more no to
man
no I think it's a valid point and this
is something that was just think about
today maybe you have a strong opinion on
this I haven't heard anyone else talk
about it they want to get rid of police
unions what's going to happen with card
check for people who don't know the left
they don't because many people in unions
don't want to be in unions so the left
wants to make sure that the Union
basically card check means everyone
knows how you voted no private vote and
they say that's to protect the worker
from the intimidating corporate overlord
but really it's the intimidating union
you can't find someone corrupt in the
Teamsters what do you think will happen
here if they want to get rid of police
unions because then there has to be some
kind of a vote or bureaucratic process
with card check they really have their
balls in a twister they do I mean there
there is this great thing we can count
on which is the left's incompetence
that's not the one saving rights that
we've got here is we could end up in a
world where after all of this insanity
it actually all backfires on the left
and we do really well but we've got to
play it smart here you know and one
thing that I think maybe some
Republicans are messing up right now is
you've got this moment where cities are
literally on fire unions are very
unpopular cops themselves actually
pretty popular and for some reason what
I don't know why conservatives are
attacking Joe Biden for being tough on
crime
they are like trying to grab defeat from
the jaws of victory this is the one time
say no Trump is tough on crime
Joe Biden is not even alive anymore
practically and you'll go weak on crime
and yet for some reason we're making the
totally wrong argument no I think you're
you're right I think there's some
validity in saying hey Joe Biden if you
really believe this why did you not do
anything for the first 50 years of your
life but you actually did the opposite
and then move on your merry way but yeah
there is a little bit it does bother me
sometimes where you see and you don't
see this so much from from Trump
necessarily or his administration but
from some of his supporters where they
focus more on the gotcha then you can
hit a gotcha right that's a jab then
move on with something else you know do
some footwork here and let people know
where you're coming from and instead
they keep focusing on the gotcha
yeah but 60 says it 72% we just talked
about if Americans want us in a national
guard focus on that do that that's the
thing to do you know and you make a
great point here on Biden which is
Biden's whole campaign is yes we're so
close to making change and progress and
you say well you were the vice president
for eight years you were a senator for
830 years I mean you've been in truly
over half a century in politics right
you didn't do it then you can't do it
now if Trump makes this argument and say
look I've been in politics for three
years now four years I've accomplished
more in that time and more good stuff in
that time than any of my predecessors
reelect me at this moment of chaos and
uncertainty and we'll get some more good
stuff that's a winning message the guy
could win you know 50 states almost now
I think you're right and what really
disturbs me most about Joe Biden is I
imagine you was breastfed very late
excuse me that vibe you know the guy who
who just like you know he had some baby
bottle tooth decay because you couldn't
get rid of bidi like even when he was
six so I don't know why and you would
think that would help with the
neurogenesis you know in the B vitamins
and almost a foot apparently just makes
you makes you demented old retards they
talk about childhood trauma here and
they'll say when Joe Biden can't finish
his sentence or when he rambles on
they'll say no it's not because he's
slipping it's because of his childhood
stutter you say okay I don't know
whether or not he had a childhood
stutter but I do know the guy has been
in politics since the 70s for some
reason we're only hearing this this
stutter or whatever it is now I think it
has more to do with the decline than the
childhood hey Joe Biden falls down a
well gets a stutter kicked by a mule it
go
back I don't know it is remarkable to me
yeah that Joe Biden has been in politics
for so many I mean I don't think this
guy has ever signed the front of a
cheque so when people talk about how
tone-deaf Americans are with the black
community's grievances and that may be
true of a lot of white Americans I'm
willing to agree that we can discuss
that but could there be anyone more
tone-deaf for example to business owners
or people who are protesting the ability
to go back and make a living then
someone who is suckled at the government
teat since he's at 28 years old or 26
with Joe Biden right I mean Joe by I
think he was 1972 or somewhere around
there when he gets elected for the first
time and he never stops you know that's
that's his whole career and I think you
make a good point too on separating
legitimate grievances from imaginary
grievances right because obviously look
there's a there is a race problem in
America that's kind of baked in they
were complaining about this evil
institution of slavery in the
Declaration of Independence it's not as
though we're the first people to realize
this is a problem right right our
founding fathers realized it too and so
how are we responding well one way is
HBO max is canceling gone with the wind
going with the wind
an actual important moment in race
relations where a black actress wins an
Academy Award how are we reacting to it
now you've got people pulling down
statues of Christopher Columbus
last I checked Christopher Columbus
wasn't the the pinnacle of racial
problems in America right last I checked
he landed in the Caribbean any crimes
you want to even accuse him of would be
against Native Americans not against
black Americans but I think the reason
they go after it is that this is not
about George Floyd this is not about
black lives mattering no matter what
that radical organization says this is
about an attack on Western civilization
Columbus is the symbol of Western
civilization and we have to wake up to
that threat before we lose our whole
culture I think it's a very good point
in Columbus one hell of a scalper let's
go to the web extended a lot of credit
calm slash Merkel of course it is
the Michael Noel's show at daily wire
and available where you can get audio
podcasts it is fantastic he's a very
very well-read gentleman let's go web
extended if you're not a member you
don't get to listen
[Music]
now the only way out you've seen a box
watch this and more at our other
channels Crowder bit em what a complete
disaster excuse me did you just blow in
from dress like a spaz Ville how do you
walk around looking like that
oh yes there you go now you're ready to
fight the man in style louder with
Crowder merch makes these two slobs look
better get your ladder with crowder gear
at louder with Crowder shop calm and
cover your disgusting body
[Music]
that was Michael Knowles of the Michael
Knowles show we went to what extent we
talked a lot about cigars which a lot of
by the way he did have to pre tape that
interview which means I had to wear this
outfit twice and we talk about my
favorite cigar and people look I took
the band off
I broke cigar you'll never know Lizz
name that movie line so I will see you
next week Monday morning are we doing
good morning mug Club I want to talk
about a few things that's next week I
want to talk about the protests how they
relate to the I guess you would say the
birth and the evolution of Dirty Harry
and Death Wish and particularly the 68
Olympics with the black fist black power
there's a forgotten portion of that
story I I've logged into Amazon now and
you see black pride everywhere yeah
every Selma only piece roots and then
that 68 is where I think it's called
there's a document in the 68 Olympics
the two guys at the podium was named
Schultz and I forgot holding up their
fist and then there was another
documentary about on an HBO and none of
them really maybe they glossed over it I
didn't watch both of them in their
entirety I did watch one but we'll talk
about that next week that's mornings of
course we put a half hour on YouTube and
an hour on mug Club so um you know you
get an extra hole hour you get a half
hour here on YouTube and it's the only
way we can continue to make a living
especially when you look at the rules
with YouTube and the grievances some of
which have been been sent to us that are
considered offensive just so you know on
YouTube you are no longer allowed to
express that you shouldn't put a child
on puberty blockers at 6 years old and
you cannot express the point of view
that we shouldn't view immigration
through the prism of race but through
the prism of shared values and ideas
that's a problem that the folks at big
tech we have some developments coming
their bill bills not in the room in I
mean someone say something so I can puff
this before I go to my say something
something
so cuz it nobody won right I mean he's
maker doodle one yeah tastes a little
bit like a snickerdoodle the other one I
had that tasted like cocoa pebbles turn
out it's because I was like sitting in
the shop for five years
oh so it was a I bought a box it tasted
nothing like it and I was very shocked
eula yeah yeah
by the way jails fine and I ordered some
cereal with your promo code so you owe
me buddy um I wanted to talk about
something here today because a lot of
people when asking my wife is still in
the hospital so I think we talked about
it Monday she had a procedure and then
she came out of it and I thought it was
GBS and then they didn't think it was
GBS and then it turns out that it is and
she's been getting treatment with an IV
at the hospital and she'll be there you
know she's supposed to be out she was
supposed to be out Saturday then Sunday
and then Wednesday and now Friday
hopefully so sweetheart I'm looking
forward to having you home it's been
it's been a little difficult but um
especially right now it's the craziest
time in her country uh so anyway that's
a completely rel when I just felt like I
owed you an update and I don't owe you
what do you want from me so I was just
listening to I hate to say this because
yeah I watch CNN and I watch MSNBC six
nine six Takashi six nine don't get me
started
you have a pink hair I do I'm close I'm
almost there you just say the same
n-word repeatedly and for some reason
word and they made all the tattoos on my
face but I do watch it sometimes the
Young Turks I don't watch or listen to
any conservative sources because I want
to be informed as to what the other side
is saying and ana kasparian did say this
is the thing when people say you're
using an extreme example to make a point
I try to avoid doing the well
Republicans do this because they hate
blacks you know or Donald Trump is
denying that us tweets are racist and
they're racist well show the tweet well
show what Republicans are saying that's
what we try to show them when we do
these clips and this is going to get to
a close where hopefully it'll it'll help
all of us because I do think the country
needs healing I don't think that it
needs healing from systemic oppression
and racism but I do think it needs me I
thought they were gonna have more
healing than we do right now with a
black president I thought that would be
the silver lining that white people
overwhelmingly elected Barack Obama
president even though he was a guy who
made sure that her money went
to funding abortion overseas even though
he made us less safe even though he made
sure we had fewer dollars in our pockets
and fewer choices in the free market
economy I said well one silver lining is
at least people will understand that the
ceiling has been totally lifted the most
powerful office and not only the land
but the globe black guy yeah I think we
all thought that right yeah I think when
we were going into that election and
when he got elected it seemed like
everybody was we're gonna bring it
together everybody's gonna be brothers
and stuff and change right though is his
slogan right change it ended up being
changed right but in the negative light
it ended up being strange pocket change
that's all I got left um but then I saw
Ana Kasparian saying not nice don't say
that audio 8 was terrible
and it's it's exacerbated by this gay
kpop huger and be comfortable with this
and be vulnerable with these closes um
so ana kasparian theand Turks said that
officers are hunting down and killing
black people just because they're black
that's what she said she said that's
what they're doing and they agreed at
that and I've agreed on that that's
echoed typically but a place like CNN
and MSNBC they they allude to it this
was actually something the Young Turks
and then later she said something to the
effect of um I think I wrote it yeah
well for people to say the officer she
was saying but for people to say the
officers shoot more white people than
black people so everything's fine you
can say that that's a stupid argument
hold on a second hold a second this is
important and this is what we don't just
make arguments for people we let them
make their own arguments no one is
making that argument no one is saying
officers shoot more white than blacks
which is true therefore everything is
fine no first part true especially when
you take into account the percentages of
crime committed when you look at
statistics and you divide them up based
on race which is what you folks do and
so we have to respond through to
misleading statistics so no one is
making the claim that well more whites
are shot than blacks true therefore
everything is fine what people are
saying in response to this argument that
people like the Young Turks and people
like Jake Tapper and people against and
Cooper make their their argument which
is that officers are hunting down and
killing black people just because
they're black what we're saying is
that's inaccurate because officers
actually shoot more white people we're
not saying obviously but therefore it's
fine we're saying no no no no no no you
were saying that officers are going out
and lynching people in a way that is
legalized modern-day and worse thing
that's inaccurate here's a stat that
shows that's an accurate no one is
saying everything is fine we are
responding to an argument that holds no
water and the reason it matters is that
if we're going to have a conversation
okay cuz people who are you gonna talk
about wearing out this conversation but
if we're going to have a conversation
and that is needed and it is needed
about police reform how to improve the
situation what we do how do we go about
that the conversation cannot be
predicated on the lie that well we need
police reform and we're gonna start with
the the jumping off point that police
are hunting down black people and
killing them because of the color of the
skin that is not what is happening
that's the point of that argument and
that again if you're a little bit
inaccurate let's say when you shoot a
target at six feet
you're really inaccurate the further you
get from there if you're at sixty feet
and if we're starting with an inaccuracy
that's a modern day lynching and it's
condoned by the government the
conversation is never going to be
fruitful on to the bigger point though
here I'm so concerned and I mean this
I'm not gonna this is just delicious
it's gonna be fantastic for an hour and
a half
I am so concerned that we are going to
see more racists than ever because of
these protests and not only because of
the proton oh because of these riots and
not only because of the media but
because specifically of how big tech has
reacted by supporting the movement and
silencing voices of dissent that is to
me is is is terrifying why well okay you
can look at these riots and you can look
at the looting and you can look at the
murder of over 20 people right now Italy
I don't know what it was it was 20 on
Tuesday including officers David Dorn
Patrick under what who were black you
can look at 400 serious critical
injuries many of them to other officers
billions of dollars likely we'll find
out in property damage and what do you
hear black lives matter black lives
matter black lives matter that's the
backdrop to average so you look at all
of this and young people are looking at
this and they say ooh that's a problem
and then they have to come to the
conclusion that a it's entirely
Tribble to race because you keep yelling
out black lives matter or B and this is
what I want young people to see and
understand this is a problem that stems
from people who don't share the same
ideas and values it's a problem of ideas
of morals of principle they've got to
pick a or B though is this a problem
with of race which is the same argument
that's made ironically from both black
lives matter and white supremacists or
is it a problem of unshared values and I
choose the latter and that's what I've
gotten a lot of flack from actual white
supremacists because I don't capitulate
to what they want there I don't believe
that it's a problem that has to do with
race here's a problem though if you do
choose the former whether you're white
supremacists or black lives matter if
you say well this is the problem because
I keep hearing black lives matter it's a
problem due to race there is no way to
not line up on one side or the other at
the end of this which will be some kind
of a race war huge and I mean a race war
the kind of which we've never seen
before and so when you have places like
YouTube and and Google and Twitter and
Facebook that say it's a problem you
know listen it's no secret we went from
the Vox at pocalypse I think a lot of
people don't know what the grievance is
necessarily were because we didn't
violate got violate guidelines one of
the problems was did you know this
something I said at the Oscars stream
where I pointed to the someone at the I
don't remem Trisha Arquette I've no idea
I said see that's a rich white elitist
Hollywood liberal spouting the same kind
of socialist message as a Honduran who
has no business being here they're here
illegally then they vote in socialized
healthcare they vote in for a system
that broke their country it's because of
people they can be rich white Hollywood
elite liberals or illegal immigrants who
do not share the values of this country
that are determined by the Constitution
and that can destroy any country from
within think about that if you have no
way of documenting who's coming into a
country in or out regardless of race we
can say this with Swedes if there is a
problem if they wanted to to bring in
Swedish policy I would be absolutely
pissed they just don't happen to
physically be south of the border
the problem is with unshared values if I
were to say that can spread and people
come in and you can't keep track of it
and then they subvert the American Way
of life liberty life pursuit of
happiness and I come from Canada where
that's not the case I come from Canada
where I easily could be jailed for some
of the things that I've said on this
show it's like I'm describing a virus
something that grows something that rots
and the same thing can be said about
right now rioting looting violence neo
check your priveledge and people don't
know what is what is this black lives
matter black lives matter and you go
well homo second I want to listen you
let's a drew brees or a Terry Crews well
you know what let's uh let's see what we
can have to get let's see if we can have
a conversation together no no how dare
you check your priveledge well I'm
trying to okay I'll just be silent be an
ally and when you say that those points
of view the view the basic [ __ ]
conservative view that I've just
expressed that um it should be about
ideas and when you've been very clear
about the ideas here in the United
States and the values and what ideas are
not welcome when you say that not that
is not permissible on the big three
Google YouTube Facebook Twitter what do
you think happens to all the people out
there who agree with that an anti-racist
message you banned them from the public
square where do they go they go into the
alleyways they run into the arms of
people saying black lives matter in the
streets and they're burning down streets
someone in Minneapolis let me give you
an analogy so when a minute twenty five
million dollars in property damage that
we knew of last Thursday in Minneapolis
alone right violence people killed
officers hurt someone's trying to get
home because maybe they're a frontline
hero a nurse right these people who you
used to love and they work downtown
they're trying to get home they can't go
through the street because it's blocked
just like you're blocking fire trucks
from protecting businesses and children
in houses you go oh my god I can't go
here black lives matter black lives with
torches and pitchforks coming down
violence they're claiming that's
representative black American they'll
get to why that's not the case
unfortunately media wants to echo it
right now and amplify it instead of uh I
can't I can't go back it's blocked the
angry mob of black lives matter and what
happens they go into an alleyway with
someone in a swastika tattoo they say
hey we'll keep you safe
that's what happens when you don't allow
reason for dissenting opinions that you
should want out there specifically
anti-racist opinions because you view
them as controversial and let me tell
you something else
um the antidote to this is uh
understanding your own human
interactions let me explain this to you
my wife is in the hospital that's why I
brought it up she's been in the hospital
she's had some great doctors some
not-so-great doctors most of the nurses
have been fantastic when I say not so
great doctors and maybe great medical
practitioners but not a great bedside
manner they can make you if you don't
know what GBS is they can make you
really scared and describing the
worst-case scenario not being empathetic
but there is a lady who I want to thank
who's been my wife's most recent nurse
for a couple of days and she is a ray of
sunshine and everyone in my family and
every visitor by the way who of course
does not support the riots or black
lives matter I can't say enough good
things about the woman this is you're
not gonna see it because I just recorded
so you just see my shoe because I want
you to hear the kind of interactions
that we have brightened my day I hope it
brightened her name by the way I can't
call her I don't know her name it's mama
I said what should I could do you want
me to call you my shoes don't you call
me by anything else you call me by
something we don't have some problems
I'm just kidding hey your wife is my
best patient she's my best I tell
everybody
she's my best patient sometimes while
you want to take him back she doing laps
all the time trying to get her on a
walker that's just cool but I want to
take a nap because she she
exhaustion I'm kissing my best patient I
love my I love your wife
we need more that every single person
who interacted with it by the way in
lady of color yeah this was a joy to be
around this person a joy to the entire
room why because she was black no ok
let's bless Pam's we're not colorblind
decadence the expressions calling her
mama
not typical of white folks there is
something funny there just like my
mother's french-canadian accent is
endearing to most so you don't have to
be colorblind and you don't have to view
people exclusively as the the sum of
their race but she was a breath of fresh
air
why not because she was black and she
didn't love my wife as a patient because
she was white she was a breath of fresh
air and she is I'm probably see her
after this because she's compassionate
she's attentive she listened and you
know what those are actions and actions
are a manifestation of character and
character is shaped by values if people
are upset about the state of America if
people feel like it's more fractured
than ever if we know we do if we need to
seek some way to find common ground not
on evil you don't find common ground
with evil but I don't believe that all
political opponents are evil but if we
are at a place where we want to find
common ground to achieve unity it will
never be possible to unify on the color
of one's skin it can't be done the only
way to unify is through values and ideas
and the greatest of those sorry I know
Aleph in the hip edgy atheists in a
YouTube comments section the greatest of
those is love now the other side of that
coin is justice it's not black or white
it's not yellow or black it's not red or
black so our first nations are black
it's about love and justice and keeping
those in mind in your personal
interactions and the solutions that we
keep in our minds and hearts as we move
forward if you think of it as white and
black black lives matter black lives
matter black one white pride white pride
two side
the same coin we can never unify we can
never heave don't buy into it don't feel
guilty for not buying into it because
buying into it is wrong and evil
see you next week Monday morning 10:00
a.m. Eastern
you
[Music]
yellow tree bears no
[Music]